- And what about fracking-
- He's trying to respond.
- I've never said I oppose fracking.
- He'll be against it very soon because
his party is totally against it.
- [Narrator] Natural gas extraction by way
of hydraulic fracturing or
fracking may not have been
the top issue on the minds
of most voters coming
into this election season.
But in the final weeks of the campaign,
they've witnessed a
frack is over fracking.
- You yourself said on multiple occasions
when you were running for president
that you would ban fracking.
- Joe Biden will not ban fracking.
That is a fact.
- [Narrator] So why so
much talk of fracking?
Because Pennsylvania is
the biggest swing state
after Florida and
fracking could be the key
to the Keystone State.
In 2016, Trump won the state
by running up the score
in blue collar counties
like those round Pittsburgh.
- To all the people of
Pennsylvania here this morning
if Biden's elected, he will
wipe out your energy industry.
- I am not, not, not
banning fracking period.
- [Narrator] Pittsburgh and
its surrounding counties used
to be united in a kind of
iron triangle of steel,
labor unions, and democratic politics
but steel and coal entered along decline
then fracking brought
new jobs, income and hope
to counties outside of Pittsburgh
which had become more republican
while Pittsburgh has turned
to tech and remained solidly democrat.
When the fracking boom
took off in Pennsylvania,
so did employment jobs and
two major components of oil
and gas extraction grew fourfold.
- What really made our company
grow was when we started
to support the oil and gas industry.
- [Narrator] Paul Bergad
owns a small business
that manufacturers foam products used by
the fracking industry.
Bergad lives and works
in Armstrong County,
just Northeast of Pittsburgh.
- In an area where we had
people leaving in mass Exodus,
it's the oil and gas that's
bringing people back.
It is the new steel mill.
Everybody knows somebody
that's in that industry.
- [Narrator] But in recent
years the US fracking industry
has essentially become a
victim of its own success.
Pumping so much gas that excess supply
has kept prices depressed
and here that's led
to less jobs in fracking.
According to data by the
US Commerce Department
by late 2019 employment
in the two big components
of Pennsylvania's oil
and gas sector had fallen
by about 26%.
- If we lose that oil and gas industry,
that is what pays the overhead,
is what pays the labor
and when you begin to take
something like that away,
the business may not be
profitable enough to survive.
- I see us reverting back
to a desperate situation
that we were before we
had the industry here
in Western Pennsylvania.
- [Narrator] Jen McIntyre
works as a consultant
for the fracking industry.
She lives and in Washington
County, South of Pittsburgh.
- It's the difference between
us being gainfully employed
or not employed?
My husband doesn't have
a degree to fall back on.
- Bergad and McIntyre say they both voted
for Trump last time and
plan to do so again.
One reason on the issue
of fracking they say
they don't trust Biden and the democrats.
- No more, no, no fracking.
- [Narrator] After a
March democratic debate
Biden's campaign clarified
that his position proposes
a ban only on new
fracking on federal lands.
While people in McIntyre's
community make their living
from the drilling economy,
a short distance away, a
growing number of workers
are part of the coding
economy in Pittsburgh
at companies like Google,
Tesla and Duolingo.
High-tech jobs now account for
roughly 24% of the workforce
in and around the city according
to the Pittsburgh technology council.
- We have a lot of great universities
and big tech companies,
but also a strong heritage
of steel working and factory
working in middle-class.
- [Narrator] Todd Medema moved
from California to Pittsburgh
about 10 years ago to study
at Carnegie Mellon university.
After graduating he stayed to work
for Uber self-driving vehicle program.
Medema recently switched to another
high-tech transportation company.
- So Google moving to
Pittsburgh back in 2005, 2006,
really kicked off a flywheel
effect where instead
of everyone leaving Pittsburgh,
they would stay, start new companies
and now we have a thriving startup scene,
multiple incubators.
- [Narrator] Most of these
tech workers hold bachelor's
or advanced degrees, these
types of voters have been
swinging away from the GOP.
- For the 2020 presidential election,
my top issue is the environment
and especially having a strong plan
to address climate change.
- [Narrator] Opponents of
fracking say it prolongs
the country's reliance on fossil fuels.
It's also become controversial
because of chemicals used
in the process that
could take water supplies
if not handled properly.
Despite fracking's downsides
Medema says he understands
his fellow Pennsylvania's
fears about losing jobs.
- People who work on the fracking
are honest hardworking Americans
and I really have no fault with them.
If you really want good
jobs, you'll vote for Biden
because he has a plan to make
the American economy
innovative and relevant
going forward not just for
today's fossil fuel industry.
- [Narrator] But voters like
Bergard are not convinced.
- When they talk about the
new jobs that will come
with solar, with windmills
the other energies,
there's nothing there that says for sure
that is gonna happen.
- [Narrator] On election
day, it could all come down
to what happens in Western Pennsylvania.
- Eight days from now we're
going to win the Commonwealth
of Pennsylvania.
- [Narrator] Biden hopes
to hold on to progressives
while peeling off some of
the pro-fracking voters
who went for Trump last time
and Trump needs more
pro-fracking blue collar workers
from this area casting ballots
for him than did in 2016.
Two groups, so geographically
close yet politically,
so far away.
(soft music)